and i have learned that purpose-driven
people and mission-driven brands and
youtube channels last
so much longer have so much more
fortitude when things get hard when it
comes to growing on youtube and you
might be like sean
bro i'm just trying to get a couple
views dog like i don't know i just want
to get my youtube channel to like 5 000
subs
i want to challenge you capture a bigger
vision
capture a bigger mission so how do you
stand out on youtube
when you feel like there's a ton of
competition how do you make your videos
better or different and how are you able
to get in front of the right audience
well
in today's episode sean cannell's going
to be diving into
three ways that you can stand out on
youtube this year
my name is heather torres and you're
listening to the think media podcast
the number one podcast to help you grow
your influence on youtube
and then use that influence to grow a
high impact and a high profit
online business and today's episode is
brought to you by our free
five-day youtube income and impact
challenge i'll tell you more about it
afterwards but you can go to
ytimpact.com
if you want to get registered right now
well let's jump into today's featured
content with sean cannell
[Music]
so how do you stand out in a crowded
niche in the midst of
rising competition on youtube you know
this is a question that i think we all
feel especially if we feel like we're
starting
late if we're just getting started and
we're like man there's so many people
that are already talking about what i
want to talk about
there's so many people that are already
covering my topic my niche
my niche and i think one of the
foundational principles it's not trying
to beat everybody
else or compare you just starting out to
somebody else that's five years ahead of
you
and like sally hogg's head said
different is better than better you
gotta find out how to be
different how to be unique so let's talk
about the most powerful way to stand out
on youtube you know i think that one of
the biggest mistakes we can make when
trying to beat the competition
is trying to be better than the
competition you know chances are
there's always going to be somebody
quote-unquote better than you so your
goal
is not to actually really be better your
goal is to be different it's to find
your
unique angle for you to find your unique
approach
and in this video we're going to be
going through layers of
depth in terms of how you can really
actually stand out that a lot of people
don't talk about you know the first
layer and
all of these tips by the way are based
on uh the book
start with why by simon sinek and if
you've never read the book before it's a
pretty good book
we'll link it up in the show notes but
you can also get a great summary on the
ted talk that's about 15 minutes that's
for free on youtube but it talks about
you know when we want to stand out as a
company
as an author as a youtube creator as a
business owner
as a church as anybody with a message
that
the kind of shallowest level that we can
stand out on
is what we do what we do trying to say
hey the reason i'm different is because
of what i do but the problem with that
is your what is going to be the same
as a lot of other people right like what
does your channel do if you're like well
i'm a gaming channel i'm a roblox
channel
i am a personal finance channel i'm a
tech channel
i am covering apple products and apple
iphone you know
channel i help moms lose weight after
pregnancy yeah you and
a thousand other moms maybe ten thousand
i help people with taxes i help people
learn the bible yeah you
and a thousand other ministries 10 000
other churches
so on the what level it can be really
frustrating because we're like
someone's already done it someone's
already doing it someone's already
you know in my niche why even start
but the powerful thing is that we can
actually go deeper you do want to define
your
what but the next level down number two
is your how
now this is this is starts getting a
little real because this is your unique
way of doing what you do
so a lot of people might have the same
what is you
in fact i guarantee you they do if
you're like shoot there's already 100
youtube channels that are like mine
great well here's how you can be
different is figure out
how you do what you do and kind of
refine your proprietary
process you know one of my favorite
examples is you think about something
like coffee now i'm a huge coffee
drinker if you're watching on the think
media podcast video i've got coffee on
the table i did a whole aeropress
this morning i had some brandy wine
coffee roasters
unique columbia and my fellow burr
grinder like i'm pretty into coffee now
coffee is a major movement across the
earth
and there's different people at
different levels in their passion for
coffee some people they're called keurig
and some
you know just really basic folgers
coffee let me know what kind of coffee
person you are other people
want to go a little bit deeper they want
the nespresso pods and then other people
are like omar on
the think media team and he's going to
have a custom roast
a custom blend he's going to have a
little scale to weigh out every little
detail
and so the what can seem pretty similar
are you a coffee drinker yeah but if you
even go into the how
now you're going a little bit deeper and
i think about in a city there's
different types of coffee shops you got
like a starbucks that's right in the
middle
how they do coffee a little bit
different it's consistent it's not great
but it's going to be the same at every
single starbucks you go to
whether in the united states or even
around the world the
another brand might be like mcdonald's
their how they do coffee is also
different it's going to be fast
it's going to be one dollar whether you
want a small medium or large
like their how is there and then i think
about local hipster coffee shops
like here in las vegas you've got
mothership coffee you've got vesta
coffee roasters
they're how as they put the art into it
the heart into it
they'll tell you where they sourced the
beans and the the roaster and the
elevation where the beans were
cultivated and was it
wash processed how were the beans
processed so that's your approach
to your niche you might be kind of raw
and off the cuff and you do live streams
and you're not super into video
production you might be really into the
art form and the storytelling
so so three people could help moms lose
weight after pregnancy but when you step
on youtube the how
some people just might kind of do
talking head and you got a personality
and you
are straight to the point you might be
more funny and you come from a more
funny approach
you might be a filmmaker and you're
really into the lighting and the
dynamics of it
there's so many different hows in terms
of
how you do your what how do you do your
what
that makes you unique you know at think
media there are certain distinctions we
like to have i think kind of some
minimalist branding we've always had
that over the years
when it comes to our music we like to
have good music and even using
royalty-free services uh we love like
epidemic sound or musicbed and different
sources
of music like that but we're picking out
we have an ear for music we care not
everybody cares they might just grab a
song
that's a different what it's a different
approach to maybe thinking about
fashion music lighting video production
and your how can be a huge way of
distinction you know think about your
how this way
who was your favorite teacher in
elementary school or high school
right like you went to all these
different classes math history
english geometry that's math it shows
how good i am at math
and so think about your favorite teacher
in elementary school you know in high
school for me was bob roleman
and it wasn't i went to i had many
different history teachers but i love
bob roman
not because of what he was teaching
history
a lot of history teachers but of how he
taught he was funny
he always saw the best in us as students
i remember my friend spencer hurst and i
we were not great students we we had a
lot of distractions
we were making some bad decisions but i
just remember he always approached us
with this air of grace of encouragement
of calling the best of
out of us of speaking life to us not
every teacher did that some just showed
up checked the box and did the what
he brought a certain how to it that made
me his favorite teacher
you want to stand out on youtube think
about how you can make your
how better and not even try to do
somebody else's how what's going to be
your unique approach
are you a mcdonald's by the way they do
well are you a starbucks they do well
too
invested coffee here in las vegas is
opening up more locations they're doing
well as
as well so think about your how it can
help
magnetize and attract an audience to you
and help you stand out in the midst of
rising competition you know chick-fil-a
they should they serve me some
crispy chicken and it's their pleasure
you know dairy queen they'll give me a
chicken sandwich
it's not their pleasure like there's no
culture there and it might be the same
chicken sandwich but like
it's not their pleasure that's how
that's that's the approach that's the
flavor that's the energy that's the love
that you put into your what
that you're creating on youtube but
friend this is not even the deepest
level
it might have been given away in the
title of the book from simon sinek
start with why the deepest level
is why do you do what you
do on youtube and the mistake people
make
is that people start with what like i
am a tech channel and simon sinek is
trying to say
in this massively global viral talk uh
to leaders to creators to business
owners
no no friends start with why
if you're leading with your why if
you're leading with your values if
you're leading with your mission if
you're leading
with your shared beliefs if you're
leading
with those things that really connect
people to you now
to be clear if you're doing kind of a
answer specific question video on
youtube you don't just go okay
we're going to get into the product
review in just a second but first let me
tell you my 20 minute story that's not
what i'm suggesting
but i am suggesting that as you weave
your
why into your content you are going to
stand out and actually build a solid
audience on youtube the reason this is
the most powerful way for building an
audience on youtube
is because people follow people
with shared beliefs and there's a
difference between
a view and there's a difference between
a subscriber and a super fan
you know you can get views on youtube by
maybe just answering a specific question
creating a certain type of video having
someone stop by your channel
but listen if you want someone to stick
people
follow people with shared beliefs
that's starting with your why
and listen people connect with people
that have
similar values so maybe
this is counterintuitive because you
felt like i don't really want to share
my values
i don't really want to amplify my
beliefs my channel is just about this
particular topic
i'd like to play it neutral i want to
challenge you that actually
by picking a side by standing out and by
planting your flag
flag in regards to your values will
actually polarize people
to you as well as polarize people away
from you
and that's a good thing because you
don't need a million subscribers
you don't need a hundred thousand
subscribers you just need 1 000 true
fans 1 000 super fans
right and this is actually a concept
that in marketing is called
values matching that when you talk about
your values
people connect with other people with
shared beliefs i'm sure you know
it's probably certain people you follow
on whatever platform
you probably follow them not just
because of good content but eventually
you really connect with them
why because of their beliefs and their
values and then conversely you might
follow somebody for a while
that even has like good tips and maybe
some stuff that you like but eventually
they they start showing their values and
you go man that's not my vibe and you
might even unfollow them
or you pay less attention because
there's either
a synchronization of values or the
values are out of match
and i remember that i used to be afraid
to talk about my faith i used to be
afraid to talk about the fact i was a
christian i used to be afraid
to actually amplify the fact that family
is my value and integrity is my value
and i believe
we need more leaders on the on the
planet right now and i believe there's a
lack of leadership for a lot of people i
believe
that you know instead of playing it safe
and sometimes maybe being polarizing by
calling people out
calling men out and saying man you got
to lead you got to rise up you got to
lead your family you got to stand for
ethics you got to stand for values
and and that i believe in god like
that's not popular to say in 2021 and
here's what i've learned
you might have just heard that you've
been like i'm out of here well cool and
i mean much love and respect to you
because
that's probably good that we decide now
that there's not a values match
but the flip side is you might go come
on amen you know preach it sean like and
there's that
there's that side where we actually can
go to a deeper level
because there's other places you could
learn youtube
they're not as good it's just my opinion
but there's other places where you could
get
information about uh you know youtube
algorithm or this that or the other
thing i would imagine
one of the reasons why you love the
think media podcast is because we are
bold about our values well hey
why is not enough you got to be good at
your what
and you got to know your how and you
have to have that dialed in
but when you start with why and you
amplify your why
you are going to attract over time
a much more powerful audience than many
on youtube and many are not even doing
this
they're focused on just the what maybe a
little bit of the how and they're not
amplifying the y and i believe that over
the next month
the next 12 months the next two years
that number one
here's the action items what are your
values
sometimes you might not even really know
like what are really your values what
what do you stand for what do you
believe in
what do you want to weave into your
content i can't you don't have to talk
about it
we don't mention our mission or our
values on every single episode
but as people hang out with you over
time are they discovering your values
and what you believe in
number two are you afraid to share your
values i want to encourage you
it actually is going to be a lot more
helpful than hurtful
because there might sure be a negative
comment there might be
you know somebody who disagrees with you
hey that's life everyone's going to have
their own opinion
but what it'll end up doing is actually
attracting
the right people to you in business i
actually think it's good to
repel customers you don't want to work
with and attract customers you do want
to work with
who would have thought you know what i
mean like if you're more it's kind of
like
dating in marriage like it wouldn't be
helpful
to hide your values until you got
married
only on the other side of marriage to
discover that like oh shoot i
i we don't we don't even sink on any of
our deepest values
so if you share them up front then right
at the beginning of the relationship you
can decide
hey is this worth even exploring at the
next level
or not so what are your values
maybe consider this what's the deeper
mission behind your youtube channel
what's your vision for your youtube
channel
what is your ideal vision for how you
believe the world should be
and how your youtube channel wants to
influence that i mean that could be
whether it's china and on from techno
dad who's in our community
he does home theater stereo but he
believes that you know we need to make
home theater is great again you know
what i mean like we need better audio
better headphones
we need to have like you're not even
experiencing the movie if you're not
getting all the sound like you don't
necessarily have to go crazy deep but
then maybe there's a cause
maybe there's something you're really
committed to like at think media we
support
40 kids through compassion international
as a team
because we care about generosity giving
back and especially here
in a first world situation that there
are people that don't live anywhere
near the privilege and the opportunity
that we have here in america
so we want to be anchored and
continuously our goal is to get that to
a hundred kids
that are getting education and they're
getting food
that's just like one of the things we do
it's one of our values like what are
some of the causes
what is the bigger mission you are on
when it comes to your
youtube channel and i have learned that
purpose-driven people
and mission-driven brands and youtube
channels last so much longer
have so much more fortitude when things
get hard when it comes to growing on
youtube and you might be like sean
bro i'm just trying to get a couple
views dawg like i don't know i just want
to get my youtube channel to like 5 000
subs
i want to challenge you capture a bigger
vision
capture a bigger mission and then
finally
i want to encourage you too that this
isn't something you can fake
that when it comes to value values
matching i'm not suggesting that you go
what should my values be so that i can
weave that into my content to
attract or connect with a particular
audience because that would just be the
worst
life ever because you'd have to always
keep up
the facade of of not actually just
living out your
values like for me if i just lay all my
cards on the table
i have a biblical worldview
the the christian bible is what shapes
my thinking so why are we driven to
generosity
because i see that in the scriptures
i am a jesus follower so i'm doing my
best failing a lot
and making mistakes all the time but i
don't consider my life my own
the final authority in my life is
scripture and jesus christ
so that is what steers and guides and
directs
my life and so when we have these values
in our company
they're coming out of authenticity as
opposed to saying like oh
you know this would be a cool thing to
do and it may be like a cool market
to reach i want to encourage you who are
you
when you really get squeezed you know
when you squeeze an orange orange juice
comes out
when you get squeezed what really comes
out but i also want to encourage you
this is what's going to help you
blow up your youtube channel attract a
powerful audience
and really build a community that can be
exceptionally vibrant because
people follow people with shared beliefs
you know past podcast episodes we talked
about
seth godin tribes as one of our favorite
books it's the thing it's like you're
gonna start gathering
with actually a tribe that already has
similar values but when you amplify your
values
amplify your why please dial in your
what even better
dial in your niche even better think
about your how and how that can be
sharper
but then really think about how you can
amplify
communicate and continue to go deeper
with your why with your vision with your
values with your mission
and i promise you you are going to see a
stronger
audience develop on youtube and it's
going to help you
stand out amongst the competition
wow well i hope that that brought you
value and that you're going to take some
time this week to
sit down and write down what makes you
different what is going to draw someone
to your content
and what is going to allow you to be the
leader in the space that you
are in uh as we move forward we are
excited
to share more about who we are inside of
our five day free
youtube income and impact challenge this
is really where
you get to hang out with the think media
team and we're going to dive deep into
challenging you to get the right videos
out to
understand what who your niche is and
what you're doing on youtube and
ultimately
how to create a high profit youtube
channel that can allow you the freedoms
and the lifestyle that you want and so
make sure you sign up at ytimpact.com
that's y
the letter y the letter t impact.com
and you can get registered for that free
five day
challenge well if you got value out of
today's episode i want to encourage you
to
like and subscribe if you're listening
or watching on youtube
and if you have the time today please go
to apple itunes
and rate and review this podcast this
helps us get the podcast
in front of other purpose-driven
entrepreneurs just like you
and allows more people to see the
content that we're putting together
to help them grow their youtube channel
as well and you may just get featured on
a future episode and today's feature
comes from twosomeone
and they said best youtube guru love
sean and his team at think marketing
they don't just teach you the technique
that they don't just teach you the
technical stuff
but also coach you through the ups and
downs of creating and growing your
youtube channel
so good lots of explanation marks and
that one
uh to someone so thank you so much for
being a part of our community
for leaving a review it means the world
to us and
if you have not shared this podcast with
a friend
i want to encourage you that you
probably know a content creator or
someone who's creative or an
entrepreneur in your life
that needs to be starting on youtube so
i want to encourage you to share this
podcast
with a friend who needs it thanks much
for listening and we'll catch you on the
next one
you